second tour de la législative partielle
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
marquée par un taux de participation de
15,3 pour cent
philippe benassaya maire de bois d'arcy
faisait face à sandrine grand gang
adjointe au maire de trappes
ils l'emportent avec 57 63 % des
suffrages exprimés
il quitte son poste de maire de bois
d'arcy afin de remplir ses fonctions de
député yvelinois dans l'émotion grande
fierté d'abord pour le l'ampleur du
résultat
malgré une faible participation cette
fois ci on aura vraiment un député
présent qui sillonnera sa
circonscription comme un conseiller
départemental sillonne son canton donc
c'est un petit peu la même chose la même
formation
la même façon de faire un député proche
des français procès des proches des
attentes
et puis aussi un député qui porte des
valeurs de son côté sandrine grand grand
me rappelle qu'à la dernière élection
législatives la gauche n'avait pas
réussi à se qualifier sa réaction face
au résultat est mitigé
réactions contrastées se dire que à la
fois une vraie déception de voir que les
électeurs de la 11e circonscription se
sont massivement abstenus malgré nos
appels à la mobilisation et en même
temps des satisfaction de voir des beaux
scores attrape le signe que il ya une
forme d'adhésion au travail que l'on
mène depuis maintenant trois mois la
circonscription n'avait pas été
remportée par la droite depuis la
défaite de jean michel fourgous en 2012
face à benoit une belle transmission
puisque en fait dans les résultats vous
avez aujourd'hui six communes sur sept
qui soutiennent donc nos idées ne venez
donc notre candidat je veux dire que
c'est une belle belle victoire depuis
ses débuts bonnes conditions de
transmission
on vient de doubler le nombre de nos
députés dans le département donc c'est
considérable je rappelle que ce
département qui avait compté jusqu'à
douze députés de la majorité
présidentielle lorsque nous étions
pouvoir dans l'opposition à monsieur
macro nous n'avons fait élire qu'un seul
député le maire de bois d'arcy devrait
être remplacé par janvier plus actuel
adjoint aux finances et aux affaires
scolaires